- All I know about Danish is the pastry.
(bouncy, upbeat music)
- [Voiceover] Aeblegrod.
- Oh see, I never understood what
the A combined with the E.
- Eblegroom.
- These are characters that I thought
were just for shitz and gigs,
like in the font category.
- Iblegrood.
- It's apricot.
- [Voiceover] Hakkebof.
- Hockay.
- It looks like Hasselhoff.
- Hasselhoff.
- Hakabeef
- Hakaboof.
- It's like it sounds
different every time.
- It's its own Danish beef.
- [Voiceover] Faedreland.
- Faderland.
- This sounds like a theme park,
Faydraland.
- Fedrooland.
- That was so awful.
- That actually...
That's a beautiful word.
- [Voiceover] Paskesondagspraediken.
- Presskondadangspradiken.
- That's one word?
- Oh!
- Okay, Sondag is obviously Sunday.
Puskasondagspradeeken.
- Paskasondangspradaken.
- Okay, I got like the first half.
- Do Danish people open their mouths,
'cause I'm the complete opposite.
- [Voiceover] Rodgrod Med Flode
- Rogro Me Floo.
- Rodgrod Me Flod.
- I'm not doing that badly.
- Redgay Me Flay
- This kind of reminds me of Calculus
more than a language.
- I feel like I'm correct
but I'm just saying it in an American way.
- [Voiceover] Vidunderlig.
- Vudunderling.
- Videgerl...
What? What?
I'ma feel like I can get this one.
- Vedooderling.
- Vindunderlig.
- You know what?
They speak like Sims.
The Sims.
- Okay, I added an extra N.
- Vidunderlig.
Oh, I got it.
I mean, it's close enough.
Vidunderlig.
- That's pretty.
That was a very pretty word.
- Wonderful. Vidunderlig!
- [Voiceover] Forarsjaevndogn.
- Yep, don't know what the cirlce means.
- I don't know what that little degree
is supposed to be.
- Forsharshado.
- There's that A and E.
- Dyn, like "dynomite".
- You have two letters in one letter,
if the word isn't long enough.
- Very, very enlightening
just to see the types of sounds
other people can make.
Like, I could never make
some of those sounds.
- It was really, really difficult.
- And it does sound like the Simsling,
which I was right on that.
- But when I heard how it was supposed
to be pronounced, I couldn't even like
understand how it's
supposed to be pronounced.
(bouncy, upbeat music)